j'ai quoditien ce que c'est ma dernière
entre il faut qu'elle soit était
violente pour eux et pour vous sur la
première ligne
on m'a écrire son nom et son prénom
capitaux à allen
je leur ai dit c'est pas ma maison c'est
votre école vous venez khamouli vienne
où il s'amusait il joue c'est l'école
c'est la mairie et la maison du peuple
il doit y aller chez rémo la gères tu
par une baguette et tu te prends une
douche chaude comme d'habitude plusieurs
suis toujours eu un côté un peu non
conformiste
il est aussi grosse que toi alors que
peut lui dire pareil j'aime bien sûr
différemment de paramétrer dans le moule
m
je suis le deuxième génération des
parents qui s'est passé commun de tous
vus comme élève ça fait dire que dans
quelques années un début c'est une
fierté aussi
on va le dire au banc d'essai ça c'est
la vraie école selection 2
henri iv a fait la paix avec des
protestations à l'armistice